The Joe Rogan experience.
But there's some sports like let's look at a power lifting or let's look
at bodybuilding. Bodybuilding is the best one. Yeah. That's doesn't exist.
It doesn't exist. Bodybuilding doesn't exist.
Bodybuilding with steroids exists by regular bodybuilding. Like, um,
I had a friend, uh, my friend Brian, uh,
who lived in Boston was a natural bodybuilder.
And he was very dedicated and he was like legitimate, natural bodybuilder.
He worked out very hard. He was, uh, he ate very clean and he was like super,
super dedicated. And you would swear he was on steroids. He was big.
I mean like big, giant arms, like really thick guy, but just really dedicated.
He is nothing like those giants that you see at the
gym that are on steroids. There are people that walk around.
Like if you go to like a Gold's gym in Venice, in the heyday,
when all the elite bodybuilders would go there,
they don't even look like humans. They look like walls with feet.
I saw it.
I went to a bodybuilding competition in Vegas for the show where we were
following this kid who was mostly not doing steroids at this time.
Like your friend,
he was trying to see if he could make it into this competition without ha the
heavy use of, uh, or heavily using steroids and other, uh, PDs.
And, uh, it was,
he went on stage and you could see the difference between him and the other
guys. I mean, everybody else there was heavily using PDs and then you'd see him.
We actually followed him. We were with this guy called Tony, huge.
Who calls himself, Tony, have you heard of this guy?
He's pretty incredible because he has a huge following, a huge following.
And he calls himself Dr. Tony, huge, even though he's not a doctor,
but he is a lawyer. Uh, and he's,
if anyone wants is interested in,
he's basically a spokesperson for steroids. He's, uh, uh,
people who are bodybuilders.
He's also a bodybuilder himself and goes to gyms and competitions.
And he was with this kid and little kids adore him. I mean,
we spoke to teenagers who look up to Tony,
huge and want to do everything he does, which is mostly PDs.
And this kid wanted to be, he went to Vegas to help this kid out.
And in the middle of it, he was like, 19.
I believe his name is Zach from Florida. Super nice kid met his mom, all of it.
Uh, but had, had,
had tried steroids had had sort of a bad experience with steroids,
decided he was going to try and do it with other things, but not steroids,
not testosterone itself, but other substances, Tony huge was helping him out.
He gets there day of the competition. He goes on stage. And again, he dealt,
looks like the others around him who have been doing steroids look so much
stronger than him. And he comes out yet. You know, again, super dedicated kid.
Like this is his life spent most of his time at the gym and eats right and all
that. And in the middle of the competition, Tony huge says, okay,
it's time for us to go back to your apartment and get you ready for round two.
They go back and we filmed all of this and he opens up a big suitcase.
And inside the suitcase,
it's like the Mary Poppins suitcase that more and more coming out, you know,
and, and starts him injections of insulin and all sorts. I don't know,
half of the things that he was giving and the kid's like,
are you sure this is okay? Are you sure this is okay? And, uh,
and I'm worried for him. And he says, okay,
I'm starting to feel my heart beating really fast. Uh, you know, you don't,
don't don't you worry.
And then he goes back and you can actually see the transformation in this kid's
body within an hour of him taking these drugs. I am not just,
what is the transformation? His, uh, uh, vessels,
his blood veins. Yes. We're popping his veins.
So that's something good apparently for these kinds of competitions. Uh,
that's something good. Apparently
that was my first time at a party. I should reassure. It's weird. It's so weird,
but so fascinating real life. Yeah.
I love think worlds look nothing like what I'm used to. I like,
I'm so fascinated by them.
I was watching a video last night on vice of a woman who, uh,
does, uh, bodybuilding. She's my height and my weight.
She weighed 196 pounds. And so,
and she has like, her neck is like my neck,
but her traps are even bigger than mine. They start like,
here they go straight down. Her shoulders were massive.
And she was talking like this, this is what I eat. Yeah. This is, uh,
every morning I have to consume 6,000 couch time. Like the rock. Yeah.
Like it was bizarre. It was so bizarre.
It was so strange to see this weird obsessed it's they're like
sculptors. Right. And in a way it is kind of an art form,
but what they're doing is freakish, but they're all into it.
They'll all love it.
Yeah. This Tony huge guy. Um, I actually kind of grew very fond of him. Uh,
just because he's so honest about what he does.
I don't think his message is very safe for kids, you know, especially, and,
you know, taking steroids, you know,
the side effects and you have to be careful, but yet him saying, you know,
I am basically a human experiment on myself and I'm trying all these things
and some things.
Because of him. Can we see what he looks like? This Tony huge fail, right?
These look ridiculous. She's going to love this. Oh, Tony.
Oh, no. He actually doesn't look ridiculous. He's a Tony Tony here.
There's a guy who's, uh, who died recently,
who was famous for looking ridiculous. His name is rich piano.
Do you know who that is? I remember when I was doing research for this story.
Yeah. Hearing about that. Um,
they don't exactly know if steroids killed them, but it's like,
you know, if you see a body and then there's a gun right next to the body,
like in the gun, the body has a bullet hole. Oh, it's pretty big. Yeah.
Hispanic. Yeah. But he's tiny compared to rich Piana. No. Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
he looks very good. Yeah. See, he doesn't look preposterous.
He looks like a very big strong guy,
like right there with the shirt off picture. Yeah. So it looks great.
Like that's, that is a guy who's in very good shape. Yeah. Doctor. So he says,
okay, this is a, I used to be handsome.
This was maybe six or seven years ago when I was 31 or 32.
I was still full-time and Laura were in a suit going to court, meaning clients,
dah, dah, dah. So, yeah. So that is decided, start taking steroids.
That's when he decided, is that what it says? Okay. So that,
that can be achieved naturally. That absolutely can be achieved naturally,
especially with good genetics. And that's one of the things that I had.
Do you know who Ronnie Coleman is? No.
Ronnie Coleman's if there's a Mount Rushmore of bodybuilding, he's on it.
A hundred percent. It's like Arnold Franco Colombo, uh, Lee Haney.
I mean, how many Mount Rushmore doesn't have enough heads, right?
Dorian Yates. But Ronnie Coleman is without doubt on there.
He used a multiple time. Mr. Olympia, enormous guy with,
with spectacular genetics, spectacular genetics.
And Ronnie did the podcast.
And he said that when he was he's really in rough shape now,
like he can barely walk. His back is really up. He's had many,
many surgeries and, uh,
he's basically had every disc in his back fused except for one and, uh,
has a really hard time walking and even standing up. Um, but when,
but that's because, you know, he pushed himself so hard,
so it wasn't just the steroids. He pushed himself through pain.
So when he got injured, he didn't give a.
He just kept working out hard and stacking weights and, you know,
squatting spectacular amounts of weight.
But he was, I believe he said he was 30 before he took steroids.
So he was a full-time cop. And, uh, he was competing just like,
I mean, perfect genetics, just perfect. I mean,
he's just a stud and then realize he couldn't beat.
These guys started getting his kicked. And so then he got on, like,
he had a that's what he went when he.
It was a cop pulled over by that guy. Yes, sir. Licensed,
sir, sir, sir. Don't squeeze my head like a zit.
He's uh, just a really sweet guy, too. An awesome guy.
But he was very honest about it. He's like I couldn't compete.
I was tired of getting my butt, my butt kicked. Right.
Then he started taking it.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No. A lot of people get busted. They get busted for trace amounts that are, um,
in, um, supplements,
catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.